on va passer tout de suite au dossier du
jour on va parler d'un sujet sur lequel
tout le monde sait déjà pour forcément
poser la question la vie après la mort
et personne ne sait réellement ce qui se
passe après la mort à part Daniel et
nombreux sont ceux qui ont tenté de
l'expliquer on va justement recevoir
l'un d'entre eux Stéphan Alix ancien
reporter de guerre qui a récemment
publié les résultats de 15 ans d'enquête
sur l'après-vie il sera accompagné de
Laura qui a vécu une expérience de mort
imminente qu'elle raconte également dans
un livre regardez ça ça passionne tout
le monde vous allez voir ce qu'il
raconte c'est fou hein après on est on
est rassuré en fait voyez ou pas moi je
dirais que j'avais toujours peur pour
vous Daniel Gill et tout B maintenant je
dis c'est pas grave mais ça va faire du
bien ça va faire
ant alors que la fête des défuns a lieu
aujourd'hui de nombreux Français se
demandent s'il y a une vie après la mort
une personne sur TR croit qu'il y a une
vie après la mort la mort certains
Français l'ont frôé de près et affirment
avoir vécu une expérience de mort
imminente d'un coup je sens que je sors
de mon corps journaliste écrivain et
réalisateur St Alix affirme lui à
travers le titre choc de son dernier
ouvrage que la mort n'existe pas la mort
est un moment de métamorphose qui se
caractérise par une continuuité de notre
conscience tandis que Laura qui a vécu
une expérience de mort imminente sera
sur notre plateau Stéphane Alix qui a
effectué de nombreuses recherches sur
l'udola nous dévoile ce soir dans TPMP
le résultat de 15 ans d'enquête sur
l'apré-ve c'est le livre du moment la
mort n'existe pas c'est le bestcellerire
du moment disponible depuis le 4 octobre
aux éditions Harper Collins euh alors
euh merci Stéphan Alix d'être là ça ça
passionne tout le monde je sais qu'il y
a plein de gens qui me disent on attend
cette séquence depuis le début de
l'émission euh vous vous présenter comme
quelqu'un de plutôt cartésien et
pourtant après le décès de votre frère
dans un accident de voiture en
Afghanistan en 2001 vous décidez de vous
intéresser au sujet de la vie après la
mort euh vous avez donc enquêté de façon
scientifique sur le sujet et vous avez
donc sorti ce livre que s'est-il passé
pour vous pour vous après la mort de
votre frère bah comme la plupart des
gens qui sont touchés par un deuil c'est
c'est stupéfiant c'est inattendu ça ça
ouvre plein plein de questions mon frère
est mort il avait 30 ans j'avais 32 ans
à l'époque et euh et voilà ça ça ouvre
tout un champ de questions qui sont des
questions qu'on a peut-être dans
l'adolescence des grandes question
existentiell qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
quel est le sens de la vie est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir une vie après sauf que moi
j'étéis ni euh philosophe ni expert en
théologie j'avais envie de réponses de
journalistes des réponses concrètes et
scientifiques et vous en avez eu vous en
avez eu euh lors de vos études vous avez
rencontré des cas de mort imminente
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
exemples parce que c'est vrai que ça euh
ça passionne les gens et ça nous
passionne et ça vraiment ça ça ça nous
intrigue est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler il paraitt qu'il y a l'histoire
de l'homme et de son dentier c'est quoi
cette histoire bah ça c'est c'est un des
cas de de témoignage qui a été rapporté
dans une étude scientifique publiée dans
une revue qui s'appelle The Land 7 c'est
un monsieur qui est arrivé aux urgences
dans le coma il était scianosé donc bleu
euh on a tenté de le ranimer l'équipe
s'est acharnée à essayer de le ranimer
parce qu'il était assez jeune donc il
s'est dit on a peut-être une chance de
le de le ramener et l'infirmière qui a
essayé de l'intuber a vu qu'il avait un
dentier donc elle a enlevé le l'appareil
dentaire elle l'a intubé il a fallu 1 he
et3 avant le de le ramener à la vie et
une fois qu'il était ramené à viille il
a été emmené en salle de réveil et quand
il s'estevit il dit mais où est mon
dentier et personne ne trouvait le
dentier et et puis une semaine à peu
près après son son admission
l'infirmière qui l'avait intubé qui
était parti en congé est revenu à
l'hôpital et quand il la voit arrivé
dans sa chambre dit mais c'est elle
c'est elle qui sait où est mon dentier
pendant que vous étiez unement ranimé je
vous ai vu enlever mon dentier j'étais
au plafond je vous ai regardé je vous ai
vu le mettre sur un chariot de secours
et je vous ai vu m'intuber et me sauver
ah donc il est ah ouais et des cas comme
ça bah comme ce que pourra raconter
Laura éventuellement c'est c'est des
extrm fréqu la partie de sortie hors du
corps la partie où la personne qui vit
un arrêt cardiaque un accident de
voiture un accident sur un bloc
opératoire au lieu d'être inconsciente
comme a priori elle devrait l'être
puisque son cerveau fonctionne plus ou
très mal elle est au plafond en train de
regarder ce qui se passe elle est donc
qu é entre la vie et la mort c'est quoi
bah le cerveau il est en sessation
d'activité au bout d'un arrêt cardiaque
10 secondes après un arrêt cardiaque le
cerveau il stoppe d'êt irrigué donc il
ne fonctionne plus il est en pause il
est en standby donc là a priori plus
d'expérience de conscience possible et
pourtant 20 % des personnes quion ramè
d'un arrêt cardiaque disent non
seulement avoir été consciente mais
extrêmement consciente avoir vu le
tunnel la lumière c'est les tous les
tous les réc c'est quoi les les récits
parce que c'est vrai le tunnel la
lumière est-ce qu'on peut revenir
àdessus c'est tous les mêmes ils disent
quoi bah c'est une expérience de qui est
difficile à décrire déjà pour les
personnes qui qui les ont vécu parce qu'
il y a comme une espèce d'intensité de
vie que tu n'as pas au quotidien dans
notre existence donc déjà c'est
compliqué qu'est-ce que ça ve une vie
plus intense que notre réalité donc il
décrivent cette intensité il décrivent
une lumière qui n'est pas éblouissante
qui qui rayonne d'amour ils décrivent la
rencontre parfois avec des proches
desess ou avec des figures spirituelles
des êtres de lumière c'est assez récurux
il y a des vraiment des constances quel
que soit le pays quel que soit le le le
c'est quoi donc un moment ils voit un
tunnel avec la lumière un tunnel avec la
lumière et il y a souvent un moment de
non retour un moment où ils ont
l'impression de pénétrer dans dans cette
ce qui ressemble pour eux à la mort et à
un moment il y a soit une phrase qu'
aurait ditite soit quelqu'un qui
apparaît qui dit non c'est pas le moment
tu dois revenir et là il y a un
mouvement de recul de de retour vers le
corps je me souviens d'un patient qui
m'a dit j'ai l'impression de réintégrer
mon corps comme quand on renfile une
combinaison de plongé mouillé après
l'avoir extrait c'est froid c'est
douloureux c'est étriqué alors qu'ils
étaient dans quelque chose de de d'une
grande félicité mais moi pour le
journaliste que je suis il y a un
élément de ces expériences qui pour moi
est vérifiable et intéressant c'est la
partie où ils sont hors de leur corps et
ils décrivent cette promené dans le bloc
où ils étaient opérés par exemple ou sur
la scène de l'accident ou parfois assez
à distance comment expliquer que des
personnes qui sont dans un état comme ça
avec un cerveau qui fonctionne plus du
tout ou très mal puissent puissent
décrire des chose qui se passe dans une
pièce à côté dans un bloc opératoire et
des des cas comme ça il y en a pas un il
y en a pas 10 il y en a des centaines de
milliers incroyable alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent à
21h avec vraiment la mort n'existe pas
le livre de Stéphan Alix que vous pouvez
nous raconter cette histoire du
chirurgien qui fait la poule bah ça
c'est encore un autre cas qui est assez
rigolo enfin rigolo ouais c'est un un un
patient qui a subi une opération à cœur
ouvert et qui va voir un psychiatre qui
est un de mes amis que je connais bien à
qui il explique avoir vécu pendant son
opération une expérience de mort
imminante classique il est sorti de son
corps et il dit mais d'ailleurs il y a
un truc qui m'a interloqué c'est que
j'ai vu le chirurgien qui était en train
d'opérer mon cœur et d'ailleurs j'étais
en train de voir où il était en train de
travailler sur le l'infarctus j'ai vu
mon chirurgien faire la poule et le le
le le psychiatre dit mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez dire bah il était comme ça
et puis il battait des ailes comme s'il
était une poule donc le mon ami
psychiatre est interloqué il dit mais je
connais le chirurgien parce qu'il est
dans le même hôpital donc il va voir le
chirurgien et le chirurgien est
d'origine japonaise et déjà extrêmement
surpris qu'on lui dise ça et dit bah
effectivement je fais pas la poule mais
euh là où j'ai appris la chirurgie pour
éviter de contaminer les objets ou les
les ustensiles de chirurgie j'ai
l'habitude de poser mes mains sur mon
poitraille et de désigner à mes
assistants les objets à prendre le
bistouri et cetera donc le le le type il
avait la poitrine ouverte le cœur dans
la main du chirurgien qui était en train
justement d'opérer son infarctus comment
est-ce que il peut on peut expliquer en
s'imaginant que le cerveau fabrique la
conscience parce que ça sert la grande
thèse que je démonre dans le livre on
vit comme s'il était une évidence que
notre cerveau fabrique notre conscience
que notre cerveau fabrique qui nous som
som or quand le cerveau ne fonctionne
pas 20 % des gens ont une expérience de
grande conscience une âme c'est ça c'est
la preuve de l'âme en fait cette
histoire selon vous que se passe-t-il
pendant que quelqu'un décède bah on
change on il y a une forme de continuité
il y a un un maître spirituel tibétain
qui m'avait donné cette image assez
parlante il m'a dit vous voyez quand
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vous dormez
vous êtes dans votre lit vous fermez les
yeux vous êtes conscient et puis moment
vous perdez connaissance et vous vous
réveillez vous êtes en train de rêver
vous êtes dans votre rêv vous savez pas
que vous rêvez vous savez pas que vous
êtes endormi vous êtes dans une nouvelle
réalité celle du rêve la mort d'après ce
maître tibétain c'est un peu la même
chose c'est que tu es tu es dans ton lit
enfin es dans ton lit tu es là où tu es
en train de décéder il a quelque chose
qui lâche il y a une perte de
connaissance et puis tu reprends
conscience tu comprends pas trop ce qui
se passe tout de suite peut-être tu peux
trop comprendre très rapidement
peut-être ça pe prendre du temps souvent
les personnes qui décèdent dans un
accident comme mon frère par exemple
accident de voiture bah ça va être un
petit peu stupéfiant parce que tu
t'attends pas à mourir comme ça d'un
mais alors ça veut pas dire que tu vas
en enfer ça veut pas dire que tu vas
devenir une amérante ou un fantôme c'est
juste un moment d'un peu de surprise qui
va demander un certain temps
d'adaptation il y a une forme de
continuité les scientifiques parlent de
continuité de la conscience il y a pas
d'arrêt tu ve nous on s'imagine que le
cerveau s'arrête tu meurs c'est fini il
y a plus rien non il y a pas d'arrêt ça
continue ça continue plus dans notre
corps et on fait quoi après al bah ça
c'est ah ou on sa pas ça reste un
mystère Mo je me suis déjà borné
continue je me suis comment il y a un
copyright non mais c'est c'estou vous
êtes déjà m' dit vous êtes déjà voulez
me dire quel ch moi je me suis déjà
essayé de attaquer à à vérifier que les
preuves scientifiques attestant que la
conscience survit à la mort du corps
existe et sont suffisamment présentables
et compilable c'est ce que j'ai
rassemblé dans ce bouquin après
qu'est-ce qui se passe après ça sera
peut-être le tome 2 oui ou l'émission de
demain bah oui avec plaisir on va on va
parler de de plein de choses c'est quoi
le le Remote Viewing utilisé par la CIA
bah ça c'est une des techniques qui
permet de montrer justement que notre
cerveau euh n'intervient pas dans
certains de nos capacités de perception
c'est la ça s'appelle la vision à
distance et ça été utilisé par les
services de renseignement américains de
l'armée de la CIA pour espionner à
distance c'est les voyants c'est les
voyants le le le programme s'appelit le
programme Stargate il a
été
Stargate ah ou d'accord oui il a été
évalué par le Congrès américain tout ça
est officiel toutes les sources sont
dans le bouquin c'est pas du tout des
des fantasmes qui sortent d'une série
télévisée c'est vraiment des choses qui
ont été étudié donc il y a eu des
centaines de missions par exemple je
connais bien des un des espions qui
s'appelait Joe mmegel enfin s'appelle
toujours JO guul à qui on demandait dans
une pièce de sa base militaire aux
États-Unis d'aller voir ce qui se
passait dans un un un bunker bizarre au
fin fond de la mer Baltique en Union
soviétique il y va comme s'il sortait de
son corps il voit dans le dans le
bâtiment une énorme structure il revient
en disant j'ai l'impression qu' c'est en
train de construire un sous-marin géant
ses analystes lui disent non mais
n'importe quoi un sous-marin géant ça
peut pas c'est pas possible refaites une
mission il repart là-bas il décrit le
sous-marin il décrit la structure et il
dit bah d'ailleurs ce sous-marin il va
être mis en service dans quelques mois
d'ailleurs tout le monde se fout de lui
parce parce que là c'est vraiment trop
énorme et puis c'est 4 mois après les
les satellites américains qui survolent
la zone en permanence voient un
sous-marin géant à ponter un autre
sous-marin soviétique c'est les classes
les sous-marins de la classe typhon
qu'on a vu dans le film avec Shan
Connery à la poursuite d'ctobre rouge
bah voilà ce voyant avait vu la mise en
place de ce sous-marin 4 mois avant
qu'il soit photographié par les
Américains des missions comme ça il y en
a des centaines et ça ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on a en nous mais toi
aussi tous on a une capacitéall voir à
l'extérieur de notre corps ça peut être
on peut être formé à ça moi je l'ai été
c'est stupéfiant ça marche quand tu es
voyant de naissance
quand je reviens dans 5 minutes pas
nécessairement voyage astral c'est le
voyage astral c'est ce que certains
appent voyyage astral ah ouais je quand
on sort de son corps pour all VoyaG je
la semaine prochaine non
non c'est quoi la conscience dont vous
parlerah c'est les religions parlent de
l'âme moi je parle de conscience
fondamentale c'est une démission une
dimension que nous portons qui nous
constitue qui n'est pas liée à
l'activité de notre cerveau nous on
pense que la conscience c'est notre
sentiment d'être nous-même notre
individu notre personnalité et que c'est
forcément lié à l'activité de notre
cerveau or tout ce que je présente dans
le bouquin démontre que quand notre
cerveau ne fonctionne plus on continue
d'être conscient est-ce c'est l'âme
c'est voilà une dimension fondamentale
qui nous constitue et qui est immortelle
justement n Laura Blanchon qui est avec
nous qui a vécu une expérience de mort
imminente entendre son histoire et elle
est incroyable vous avez une méningie
foudroyante oui euh vous ê êtes resté 10
jours dans le coma et vous êtes
finalement miraculeusement revenu à la
vie est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
votre expérience de mort imminente ce
que les téléspectateurs quand vous allez
elle va vous raconter ça c'est vrai que
c'est c'est c'est c'est incroyable
lorsque je suis tombée dans le coma euh
j'ai vécu une sortie de corps c'estàd
que le souvenir que j'ai en me
réveillant du coma c'est c'est de me
voir au-dessus de mon corps ouais de
voir les machines mon frère mon père je
pouvais tout resituer dans la pièce et
je pouvais même dire ce qu'il m'avait
dit alors qu'à ce moment-là
l'électroencéphalogramme il était plat
donc pas d'activité cérébrale
ensuite mon père me dit et je l'entends
je préfère que tu meurs plutôt que tu
souffres et à ce moment-là j'ai
l'impression de m'envoler de partir et
j'arrive dans une atmosphère
bienveillante je me suis jamais senti
aussi bien que que là-bas ah ouais et
ensuite c'est des séries de Rê pendant
le quand je me réveille du coma je je
raconte tous ses rêves et je fais des
liens et entre autres bah je vois mon
arrière-grand-mère qui qui prend soin de
moi je rencontre aussi une personne âgée
que je ne connais pas qui m'explique
qu'il est là pour prendre soin de moi et
que je vais repartir que je vais revenir
vous avez vu le le grand-père de votre
mari sa maison alors qu'elle ne vous
connaissez aucun des deux les souvenirs
de ce rêve là que je raconte je décris
le le grand-père la maison les arbres le
poulailler je peux tout vous situer
comme on se souvient d'un rêve et en
parlant avec ma famille ma belle famille
de mes rêves ma belle famille me dit on
direct tu racontes la maison de chez
pépé c'est fou donc mon beau-père m'a
emmené dans cette maison à à 4h de chez
moi et on retrouvait tout au même
endroit il manquait une chose c'était un
seul pleureur qui n'était pas qui était
dans mon rêve et qui n'était pas dans le
jardin et mon mari m'a emmené et il y
avait une souche d'arbre il m'a dit
quand j'étais petit il y avait il y
avait un seul pleureur à cet endroitouf
c'est ouf alors incroyable votre
histoire c'est quoi cette histoire de
restaurant chinois pardon C hisire de
restaurant chinois parce que je disais
qu'il y a des rêves qui sont
inexplicables comme celui-là mais il y a
des rêves qui sont aussi explicables euh
je me souviens que ma mère m'emmène dans
un restaurant chinois et qu'elle me
tient et qu'elle m'étouffe avec une
amande ah ouais ça fait partie des rêves
et lorsque je raconte à ma mère ma mère
me dit mais en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il fallait te réintubé et tu
étais trop euh tu bougeais trop je t'ai
tenu avec l'équipe soignante et il y
avait une personne asiatique qui sentait
fort la nourriture asiatique qui te
tenait avec moi et donc dans mon cerveau
ça s'est transformé en restaurant
chinois et ma mère qui essayait de
m'étouffer mais là pour le coup ce rêve
là on peut faire des liens avec ce qui
s'est passé dans la vraie vie mais pas
pas sur les autres h c'est incroyable
c'est
incroyable mais ce qui est fou c'est que
les histoires sont incroyables et
toujours positives c'estàdire que vous
êtes dans un allo vous discutez avec des
gens il y a jamais de sensation
désagréablebl tout es toujours dans un
univers merveilleux je sais que ça
existe mais pour moi ça a été une belle
expérience vraiment j'ai jamais été
aussi bien qu'à ce momentlà et je
voulais pas revenir ah vous vouliez plus
revenir ah ouais je me suis réendorm
j'ai eu la sensation me rendormir et je
me suis réveillée à l'hôpital ouais mais
il y a des personnalités hein qui ont
vécu des ce qu'on appelle Near Death
experience expérience de mort imminente
Philippe Lab qui travaille sur C8 a
raconté qu'il avait vécu ça
et il raconte effectivement qu'il est
au-dessus du corps et il y a toujours C
ces choses de de le couloir lumineux ou
de bien de bienveillance d'apaisement il
y a mundir aussi ah ou m'a écrit en
direct il m'a dit que aussi il avait vu
il a vu mais il a vu une lumière je lui
dit non c'est juste tu les phares de ma
voiture
non mais c'est vra il est con est-ce que
est-ce que vous vouliez plus revenir
c'est ça qui est fou vous
éti ouais il est total et en plus tu
penses même pas à tes parents ou à ton
copain que tu as laissé tu penses plus
qu'à toi c'est très égoïste mais c'est
plus rien ne compte plus rien ne compte
juste c'est un bien-être total
alors juste Stéphane qu'avez-vous qu'est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut découvrir après la
mort c'est quoi bah que ça compte
continue moi je trouve que c'est déjà
une bonne nouvelle ça genre ça continue
mais il y a quoi parce que il y a il y a
des
a soir il y a du
padle je pense que je pense que
quelqu'un qui qui apportera une réponse
détaillée sur cette question là faudra
s'en méfier parce que c'est c'est une
question tellement vertigineuse que on
sort un peu de mon domaine de compétence
moi je suis journaliste je suis pas
encore une fois théologien donc je me
suis contenté déjà de de montrer que le
mythe moderne notre croyance moderne qui
postule que notre cerveau fautc notre
conscience c'est une hypothèse qui tient
pas la route après que devient notre
conscience quand elle est plus
prisonnière de notre cerveau quand tout
d'un coup elle regagne ce que dit leura
et ce que disent beaucoup de témoins
d'expérience de mort imminante c'est
qu'ils ont l'impression de se réveiller
en vivant cette expérience de mort
imminante comme si là on vivait dans une
forme de sommeil euh alors est-ce qu'on
se réveille est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire une réalité plus grande on a
plus de limitation d'espace et de temps
on peut se déplacer dans le temps et
dans l'espace sans que ça pose le
moindre problème Laura s'est déplacé à
une certaine distance il y a des témoins
qui disent je suis parti à 4000 km en
une fraction de seconde comme ça ouais
donc ça va faire des économies hein ça
oui en fait ce qui est magnifique c'est
que grâce à votre livre on arrive à
matérialiser l'existence vraiment de
l'âme et on comprend du coup que dans
cette vie c'est important de prendre
soin de son corps effectivement mais de
son âme aussi parce que son âme c'est
celle qu'on va continuer à garder et
donc faire le bien pour le bien de son
âme
important c'est important de faire le
bien parce que c'est comme ça qu'on rend
notre âme plus belle parce qu'on va la
garder pour toutes les prochaines compte
ça parce que moi j'ai j'ai des points
Mo non mais j'ai des point mosi merci de
ça parce que pour moi c'est vraiment
important notre âme notre dimension
spirituelle elle va pas forcément se
révéler au moment de la mort cy elle est
là maintenantelle sprime comment St pour
regagner des points
comme ça mais l'âme elle s'exprime
comment pour toi pour tous les gens l'me
elle a chanté elle est
loinavers l'me elle notre notre âme elle
s'exprime à travers notre intuition
notre cerveau non seulement il fabrique
pas notre âme mais écrase il l'empêche
de s'exprimer et donc tous les moments
où on réussit à se reconnecter à son
intuition c'est notre âme qui nous parle
c'est notre âme qui et notre âme elle
connaît les réponses elle connaît les
les grandes les grandes orientations de
notre vie elle est capable cette
intuition parfois de nous nous amener
sur le chemin qui va être vraiment le
chemin de de notre vraie cohérence
intérieure quoi et c'est c'est en sens
et c'est notre cerveau qui peut nous
contre qui peut nous induire en erreur
normalement il faut écouter son âme et
parfois notre tête nous fait prendre son
âme que faut essayer de découvrir
comment son intuition s'exprime à
travers soi pour bien la différencier de
nos désirs de nos de nos fantasmes
secrets mais on a tous une petite voix
la petite voix de notre âme à
l'intérieur de nous et je pense que un
une des magies de la vie c'est d'essayer
d'apprendre à l'écouter et à en tenir
compte le plus souvent possible dans
notre existence ben en tout cas je vais
continuer à écouter l'âme et non mais
c'est vrai qu'elle chante pour ceux qui
sont loin de chez eux je l'embrasse fort
merci Stéphan Alix d'avoir été avec nous
merci également Laura et vous prépare un
bouquin merci à vous merci d'avoir été
avec nous c'éit incroyable oui merci
tout de suite c'est les chevaliers du
fel en direct sur
C